so gambit you throw stuff yeah I tap
into the energy of an object and I turn
it into kinetic energy and then you
throw it yeah I trow it I truly really
hard yes um I'm just gonna keep it then
as throws stuff which is what I had
dammit my question then is um what
happens if you run out of stuff ah but
there's always stuff to try as always
yeah and I got my plank right you great
to have you on the team
that was tough because you know this is
a new deck and they're all little slick
you know you know yeah it's good to work
them in a little bit throw them a bunch
yeah I understand what if you run out of
cards how about you know professor it
doesn't have to be the playing card it
can be any type of oh oh you could throw
a business card yeah yeah you could do
maybe a new no I own ozz could you throw
a Magic the Gathering card it's quite
fitting baseball or any spar
what about a greeting card yeah it's a
little thick but you know I can look you
could cool yeah no no no without cards
you're garbage
I control other things you know like you
in my pocket I have some change you know
because I had a gyro earlier I had a
lunch oh so if we were attacked by
sentinels at lunch perhaps you could
have thrown the hero yeah yeah you can
true a gyro by this stuff custom meets
floppy scatters the meat I'm sorry
you're still missing with me on you
indubitably
are you hearing as we're speaking how
incredibly lame you are so you're fired
no yes I am firing you because without
stuff you are worthless
what if we're attacked and we're not
inside of a 99-cent store or in the
paper plate aisle of a Target or perhaps
at some knick-knack flea market in New
Hampshire hmm what then I got the backup
you know cuz I got the staff you
remember me what the staffed oh I didn't
look in the file you have a staff you
trained underneath the waterfall with
the staff to do that uh-hmm
I trained up training on the stage if
the x-men ever have a parade we'll put
you right at the top when
you hold that staff you look like the
world's biggest blade fam do you
understand
you look like you brought it to lean on
as you wait in line overnight for the
new Twilight book not movie
what are those gloves go fingerless or
go finger those are the choices
none of this cats is coming back to
Broadway [ __ ] here's some fingerless
for you suck on it okay
I'm Monica you know it's it's not
goodbye
gabbi's if we're ever attacked while
we're all playing inside of a ball pit I
will call you we think you would know
now would you throw yourself out I could
melt you with my mind